sara is on the line in sacramento hi
Sarah how are you I'm good grateful for
every day how are you better than I
deserve what's up in your world I have a
little bit of situation it's been a hard
couple of months I have two little boys
there are five and six and I am about
seven months pregnant with my third boys
and recently in November my husband was
incarcerated and then also the very next
day I was diagnosed with cervical cancer
so the last couple months have been
pretty tough Wow but we have managed to
keep our heads above water I've managed
to get the bills you know I've basically
scratched and clawed everything I could
do you know I'm working more hours I'm
cutting back on bills that are
unnecessary I cut off my phone bill I
cut off my cable adjusted PG&E and car
insurance just anything that I could
adjust to these changes I've done and it
has been okay so far you know love you
know we haven't lost their home we rent
so I've been able to to keep everything
okay you know my kids that have
everything that they need so that's the
most important thing but I'm kind of
just wondering so when did you get your
when did you get your cancer diagnosis
November attempt and my husband was
arrested on November 9th
so being pregnant and dealing with
everything yeah I think I cried so so
first like 30 days but now I am just in
mother mode all the way through what
through Thanksgiving for sure I don't
blame you Oh so what is uh what is your
income I make about 17 an hour I work
full-time and how long will he be away
it is you know it honestly he couldn't
if it could be two to three years
looking at our best circumstances and it
could be never him coming home so I'm
kind of just hoping for the best and
planning for the worst at this point
what was he charged with I mean I can't
really talk about anything over this
hasn't been charged to yet but it is a
pretty well there's a rest okay okay
Chrissy is a committee and are they
holding him now yes they're they're
holding him and until they have a trial
mm-hmm and what is your house payment
are your rent and the whole entire rent
is 1,500 but it luckily one of my
husband's friends has rented out a room
for 500 so I paid a thought was another
right now and how much debt do you guys
have not too much luckily I have been
working on on debt already I closed
about $20,000 worth of debt last year so
I have about 500 left 500 dollars mm-hmm
500 on little random miscellaneous items
so what is the doc saying about your
cancer treatments um I can't really move
forward it is very I caught it very
early luckily because of my prenatal
appointments they found it very early so
that's good I cannot do any any type of
treatment at this point because I am
seven months pregnant but afterwards you
know I do they do think I have a bright
future looking forward I can have some
treatments a couple weeks after the baby
is born and you know hopefully
everything will be okay after that and
that's early enough to catch it all okay
sounds good for a bad situation all
right yeah all right what do you do for
a living I work at I do data entry and
accounts receivable position how old are
you 27
yes family in the area no I don't have
part of that the thing that's been hard
when me and my husband got married I
moved about an hour and a half away from
any of my family or friends so getting
the kids to school and to work and
doctors appointments everything is kind
of on me right now well I think it
sounds like what you've told me is we
need to treat you like a single mom
mm-hmm
that's 27 years old with two little boys
and another one on the way was cervical
cancer
I mean I've got a daughter that's 28 so
what would I want her to do I think I'd
want her to move back closer so we could
get family support around her mm-hmm
could you get a job back at the hometown
um yeah I'm sure I could I mean I'm kind
of juggling priorities and trying to UM
make a list of pros and cons for myself
you know we do have a pretty big house
it's only booked my job is about a mile
a little pretty big house you can't
afford yes true thousand dollars of my
thousand dollars a month I mean thirteen
hundred a month after that somebody pays
you five hundred is a lot of rent for
somebody making $35,000 a year with two
kids find three kids soon fighting
cancer so I'm I'm looking for a job home
that's a closed or equivalent and I'm
moving before the baby comes
okay if I'm you that's not what you
wanted to hear but I think you've got to
get you just got so much I never heard
anybody's got so much on their plate I
mean you got a truckload of stuff here
kiddo and where is home it is in Fremont
California about an hour away from where
I'm living now okay north south where's
Fremont it's kind of by Oakland is it's
more attractable okay yeah I know I know
where you're downtown the south side of
Napa okay yeah III I mean if your family
has any anywhere near functional and
they can provide you some support while
you're having a baby fighting cancer and
trying to raise three boys they don't
have to give you money necessarily but
boy just some people around you to lift
some stuff would be handy I mean you got
out of my family I'm kind of a more
independent one you know it's either me
living on my own with my sons and they
can have their own rooms and the things
that they decide
on your own I just said be in the
neighborhood are you plugged into a good
church there in Sacramento that can come
around your home started recently
started going to church and doing little
things to work on myself this was a
positive motivational videos well what I
was trying to when I was the point was I
was trying to get family around you and
so you know I think you swing by that to
talk to that pastor and tell him what's
going on and give that church an
opportunity to be a blessing to you in
terms of giving you some support I
appreciate how independent you are kiddo
but there's nobody independent enough to
carry everything you're carrying by
yourself you just need some people in
your life that love you well and that
will walk with you and carry parts of
this and you're gonna have to move into
cheaper housing ultimately okay my next
step I mean water this far but I think I
think you're hanging on by your
fingernails financially yeah as far as
the money the math part goes it's really
really tight so here's what we'll do
whether you decide to move back home or
whether you just decide to stay in the
area and plug into that good church and
they'll help you will help you either
way I'm gonna put you on hold Kelly's
gonna pick up I'm gonna put you in one
of our coaches as a gift
we're not you're not paying for anything
we're gonna help thank you and I want
you to go through our class Financial
Peace University too and I want to pay
for that and we'll try to walk with you
but you got some tough decisions to make
I'm so sorry kiddo but you call me back
as you're making the decisions and as
you got questions I'll help hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show
[Music]